welcome back to business someone just
tweeted me asking how I'm feeling about
the cricket but how do you think I'm
feeling about the cricket
England and Australia
dead and buried and then the rain ruined
it so obviously I feel sickened
absolutely sickened but thank you for
asking an angry diplomatic route between
Sweden a number of Islamic majority
countries has erupted over the weekend
it comes out of copies of the Quran were
burned and stamped on as part of protest
by an Iraqi Asylum Seeker in Stockholm
Pakistani protesters held anti-sweden
protester retaliation and Iraqi
protesters Set Fire to the Swedish
Embassy in Baghdad the incident once
again raised a debate around whether
Free Speech always has the right to
offend even the most firmly held beliefs
let's ask my special guest the author
neuroscientist and host of The Making
Science sense podcast Sam Harris Sam
Harris great to have you on Facebook
when I said to him
yeah hey Bears good to see you this line
between religious beliefs freedom of
speech is there a line that should be
drawn
well ultimately no I mean I think it's
we just have speech right we just have a
contest of ideas and when ideas actually
matter we really need our best ideas to
be operative ideas about human Freedom
ideas about
political tolerance equality among
people I mean these are these are ideas
that we really can't afford to
compromise on and I would say that that
extends to just a rational understanding
of the way the world works right so we
can't
compromise on scientific truth or
historical truth or journalistic truth
ultimately
um and I mean I think there's a there's
certainly scope for civility and
pragmatism and politeness and picking
your battles but the general picture
here is that there's there's only one
religion on Earth at the moment that
imagines that even non-members of the
religion
should be obliged to live by its
strictures right so they you know all
religions are certainly most religions
have some concept of blasphemy they
don't like it when their their sacred
objects or sacred places or sacred
figures or are defamed but
there really is there is only only one
religion that will murder you for doing
anything like that and and really
without any with a full clarity of
conscience among
uh you know even majorities in many
communities uh will will call for for
the murder of blasphemers or idolaters
or you know other others who try to
introduce the sacred tenets of the faith
even if they're not part of the faith
and and that religion is of course Islam
in its various forms and so that's a way
there is a contest between this kind of
fundamentalist intolerance and modernity
and it you know if we were dealing with
the Christians of the 14th century well
we would have a similar contest with
Christians but we're not happily and and
I I tendency with Islam I hear that
opening burning copies of the Quran I
personally I'm a massive believer in
free speech I campaign about it on the
show all the time but openly uh burning
copies of religious the Quran I don't I
think that does cross a line I don't
think you should defend that necessarily
using Free Speech as the defense should
we
well well I don't I don't defend it as a
matter of taste I'm not advocating that
people burn the Koran but I think we
should be politically free to burn any
book right we should we should just
acknowledge that books are books created
by people right and the idea that
some considerable number of people in
the Muslim world
see otherwise right and would imagine
that that a specific book is more
important than any
specific person or a group of people
that's just it's just upside down
ethically and politically in a way that
we just have to recognize it's just you
know
I mean just take it you know leave it
leave aside the burning of books just
take take just the the disrespect for
religious Traditions you have a a
Broadway play the musical like the Book
of Mormon right which was very funny and
which most Mormons didn't much care for
but what they did to protest that was
they took out ads rather cheeky ads in
playbill the the magazine that you get
when you walk into a Broadway Theater
and this was all in good fun and it was
really you know they were they tried to
recruit from Mormonism within play a
bill you know and it was it was
delightful and that was a and yet they
they voiced their opposition to the
basic project that was poking fun at
their religion but the the the the thing
to notice of course is that a a book of
Islam Broadway musical that poked
similar fun at Islam would have been and
would still be Unthinkable and not just
in Baghdad or or you know Kandahar but
in New York right I mean the the the the
the security concerns that would attend
such a production would it would be
excruciating and that disparity is it
should be intolerable to us what about
this uh story
um where the band The 1975 who a band
they go to Malaysia they know that
Malaysia has anti-gay laws but they
accept a booking to go and perform on
stage there and then the lead singer
Matty Haley decides to kiss his band
member male band member on stage in a
deliberate Act of defiance turned out
that he'd done something similar in 2019
in Dubai which also has anti-gay laws so
it wasn't his first journey on this
rodeo and it also came after
inflammatory comments he'd made which
would perceive to be homophobic and
defensive a few months ago he came out
on a podcast so it was a bit of
hypocrisy there but the basic principle
of going to a country like Malaysia and
deliberately flagrantly breaching the
conventions of that country is that a
sensible thing to do you're allowed to
do it obviously you can do it and get
all the credit you may want from Twitter
for doing it but should people do that
well I don't know I think you have to
view that on a case-by-case basis I
think there's an argument for not going
to places where there's such religious
intolerance that you just don't you
don't want to support anything about the
the the Norms in that Society or I
suppose you can go oh as this band did
and protest those norms and and
hopefully make a point that lands
politically in that society and I really
I think that's just a judgment call and
it I could go either way with that yeah
but I I mean the larger point to make
here though is that
we can't afford we the West we you know
secular societies diverse societies
pluralistic societies globally speaking
can't conform to the religious taboos of
any specific Community I mean right now
if you go on chat gpt4 and ask it to
tell you a joke about Jesus it will tell
you a joke about Jesus and if you ask
her to tell you a joke about Buddha it
will tell you a joke about Buddha and
they're not good jokes but it'll tell
you jokes but if you ask her to tell you
a joke about Muhammad it will refuse
because of the religious sensitivities
of Muslims and if you ask it about that
incoherence
um it will basically become as evasive
as Andrew Tate was when you interviewed
him well you know I was actually going
to reference I was going to reference
another interview actually which Richard
Dawkins when I asked him about speaking
out like this in the way that you've
been doing just now and his reply was
really quiet I found it quite chilling
actually take a look
are you worried about me do you get
threats because of the positions you've
taken on some of these things yeah
when you saw what happened to Salman
rush to you
didn't send a shutter three
are you saying no you don't want to talk
about it or yes
right I mean that's interesting in
itself because is it
there are areas which you would prefer
not to discuss
yes
I should have said that before we
started yeah no medicine I I'm I think
it's sad that you can't
I don't think anything should be off
limits in interviews with people like
you
I mean I thought that was really
interesting that someone like Dawkins
just would not answer out of fear it
turned out
yeah well I would have to ask Richard
what his motive was there I I can
imagine it might not have been fear but
just the the pragmatic concern that
acknowledging the the threat landscape
is in some way unwise right that you're
actually increasing your security
concerns by admitting that you have them
on some level but this is this is just
plain for everyone to see that there is
this
this vast difference between criticizing
Islam however peripherally however even
on the tiniest points you know to just
surely just depicting the prophet
Prophet Muhammad in a cartoon right
we're naming a a teddy bear uh or a bear
in a South Park episode uh Muhammad
right I mean it's just this is the kind
of thing that can get embassies burned
in a dozen cities right this is this is
just there's nothing like this coming
from any other religion and that
difference is important right I'm not
saying that people should go out of
their way to criticize Islam or any
other religion necessarily though I
think when when push comes to shove we
have to just acknowledge that
we need good reasons for believing the
our most important beliefs and and
figuring out you know how to how to
organize our societies right so it's
just one when people are resting on
Dogma we should be increasingly
impatient with that and we would be
impatient with astrologers if they were
trying to change our our laws and our
politics too
uh but with Islam we just we have to
recognize that
okay it deserves all of the respect that
every other religion does and all of the
the patients that every other religion
does in a pluralistic and diverse
Society but no more right and we see you
know we're now we're not we're literally
building it into our most advanced
artificial intelligence this this double
standard and and we're doing it out of
fear right we can call it religious
tolerance but it is just fear it's just
you know we have been successfully
bullied into having a double standard
and it's um
uh is dysfunctional and it's ultimately
dangerous I mean the problem for Solomon
Rushdie was that there were there
weren't ten thousand Salomon rushdies
the very next day as there should have
been uh and that's why he had this
asymmetric risk for for decades and and
ultimately suffered a terrible attack uh
we we should stand shoulder to soldier
with someone and
um and I I'm not saying Richard wasn't
doing that Richards is an
extraordinarily Brave public
intellectual and he's been on the front
lines of this debate for decades
somehow it's great to talk to you I
really appreciate it uh your podcast is
making sense I appreciate you coming on
the show thank you very much
yeah take care